voilà maintenant plus de deux mois qui
emmanuel macron annoncé la mise en place
d'un second confinement en france et que
les restaurants fermés de nouveau leurs
portes au public le second épisode d'une
période catastrophique pour les
restaurateurs qui depuis mars 2020 n'ont
jamais pu reprendre une activité normale
et alors que le président de la
république avait préconisé une
réouverture pour le 20 janvier
il semblerait que cette date soit
désormais impossible à tenir une
nouvelle qui met à nouveau tout le
milieu de la restauration en ébullition
ce soir nous recevons stéphane
restaurateur à besançon qui appelle à
une révolution et à ouvrir coûte que
coûte ou hôteliers restaurateurs bart
ouvry tous en même temps
stéphane merci d'être là stéphane turion
vous êtes restaurateur dans le doubs
vous avez passé un groove et pousse un
gros gros gros coup de gueule sur
facebook qui a énormément fait parler en
gros c'est simple vous voulez quoi
stéphane merci d'être là en tout cas
merci merci vous représentez vous
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
restaurateurs qui nous regardent qui
m'écrivent qui me laisse des mots sur
les réseaux sociaux qui sont à bout ils
sont au bout du rouleau combien de
restaurants je vois avec bail à céder
terminé pour nous on a fermé le rideau
j'étais dans le sud voilà il ya plein de
gens branchés des produits qui sont le
sud qui ont vu qu'ils m'ont dit voilà
tout est fermé
les gens disent on n'en peut plus il
laisse des mots le gouvernement
sauvez-nous le gouvernement on est on
n'en peut plus on peut plus travailler
on n'a plus d'argent on va mourir et
c'est vrai que donc pour représenter ce
soir aussi beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui
n'en peuvent plus et les restaurateurs
les patrons de discothèques libre
adhésion d'un événementiel c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui
comment comment on peut faire parce que
c'est vrai que ma il est vrai que les
biens sculpteur les boulangers et
pâtissiers les charcutiers tout tout
tout ce qui fait partie de l'hôtellerie
restauration en général c'est tourisme
il faut commencer alors que l'hôtellerie
restauration c'est 10 % du pib français
bien sûr s est pas rien c'est à millions
d'emplois sur les 29 millions d'actifs
en france
moi ma plus grande crainte aujourd'hui
c'est si l'immobilisme le fait que
l'état ne fasse rien je te prends un
vaccin je comprends pas je te dis ça je
te dis pas ça
24 gars tous la tête dans le sable puis
personne ne fait rien donc c'est plus
possible pourquoi parce que moi j'ai 42
ans j'ai investi toute ma vie là-dedans
c'est maintenant que vous êtes
restaurateur vous avez 25 ans 25 ans a
marqué bien pour vous ça marchait très
bien un petit resto rangement de la
truie de viviez tout se passe bien mais
au même titre que plein de caunes et
bien moi
al yehud tout va bien non je n'avais pas
à me plaindre c'était correct du mollah
fait combien de temps or on est fermée
depuis le 27 octobre
aujourd'hui un don on aura fait les
fêtes de fin d'année est la plus l'année
dernière bien entendu il exactement
en plus moi je pense surtout aux
saisonniers il faut pas oublier ces
derniers qui travaille sur les stations
d'hiver
c'est très important ben pas de
remontées mécaniques par le restaurant a
su réagir
pas de logement c'est ça que vous
comprenez pas les mecs ils travaillent
en deux saisons il travaille quatre ou
cinq mois dans l'année en station de ski
des parts un mois aux vacanciers rang
qui sur une saison 2 dt derrière ils
sont logés lundi à des grecs sont à la
rue ils sont à la rue ils ont même pas
le prochain jeu parce qu'ils n'ont pas
eu assez de temps d'entreprise
c'est une catastrophe c'est pas une
catastrophe sanitaire ou économique
c'est aussi une catastrophe pour tout
ces emplois c'est les gens ils vont ils
crèvent de faim alors on est évalué à
moi c'était ce à quoi vous stéphane
aujourd'hui comment vous faites quand
vous vous en sortez et ben je bosse fait
quoi eh ben je suis consultant
voilà je suis chef consultant donc je
suis ce qu'on appelle un chef au togo
même titre que guillaume gomez qui est
celle de l'elysée la corne chill out et
et compagnie et je vais je donne des
cours de cuisine mais votre coup de
gueule vous avez dit il faut ouvrir les
restons bien sûr qu'il faut ouvrir les
restaurants parce qu'à un moment donné
c'est plus possible mais qu'il apprend
quand la décision
un ils ont fait une réunion et bruno le
maire aujourd'hui avec lui ils savent
pas des vaccins en aura pas on sait
qu'il va falloir au moins quatre mois
pour vacciner tout le monde donc si je
suis content et on est d'accord pouvait
tenir encore un mois un mois un mois
après c'est la faillite quoi vraiment
blague je vais perdre ma baraque ma
bagnole j'ai trois gosses trocao 15
employés bonne voie et terminer
bah ouais dans un mois j'ai appris j'ai
investi amis millions d'euros l'année
dernière
d'accord j'ai racheté ce restaurant
puisque j'ai mis toute ma vie j'ai reçus
à la maison on a fait cet aoc votre
projet bien sûr de voile il ya deux ans
jeudi un an mais à deux il ya deux ans
donc on a fait tout ce travail là pour
remonter le restaurant voilà et je suis
pas le seul les discothèques j'en
connais plein mais vous parlez au nom de
plein de choses autrement voilà mais
s'est intéressée à votre cas et moi bon
pour moi c'est comment mener
j'ai sacrifié ma vie pour ce travail
c'est un métier difficile c'est 15
heures par jour trois cent vingt heures
par mois pour un salaire de misère je
gagne 1200 bâle 1 sur ma boîte 1 voilà
ce que je prends donc tu vois je suis
pas super riches
donc ce qui m'agace c'est que à un
moment donné il n'y a aucune cohérence
de l'état aucun soutien alors tout le
monde ira mais vous toucher dix mille
balles par mois et dix mille balles de
quoi qu'est mille balles par mois est ce
qu est ce que les 10000 euros de l'état
ce qui les avait pris alors on les a
pris pourquoi parce que ça beaucoup de
14000 vous parlons bien sûr le problème
c'est que moi j'ai des frais fixes
voilà donc il faut pas voir juste un
chiffre pour savoir ce qu'il ya en face
parce que vous j'ai encore des employés
qui sont en contrat donc il ya une masse
salariale qu'elle acquérait 40 faut
savoir que on est remboursé sur la masse
salariale des employés donc les salaires
nets nous seront remboursés
la partie des charges salariales peu
côté employé n'est pas payé mais par
contre la partie employeur n'est pas
exonéré ya pas de décret de sortie h 15
donc on paye nos charges
moi je paye toujours mes assurances mon
fuel j'allais ouvrir votre restaurant et
bien sûr les ouvrir qu'est ce que vous
allez faire donc là vous allez ouvrir
votre restaurant le 1er février et
j'attends j'attends juste que que le
président de la république fasse son
rôle il a été élu par le peuple
travaille pour nous un moment donné faut
qu'ils prennent des décisions pour ça
qu'on l'a élu autrement il fait comme
tout le monde allait prendre pour
évaluer le maquereau ou oui j'ai voté
pour les mâles annuel à combien sur
ouais donc là aujourd'hui vous attendez
qui vous sortent de cette ce marasme et
qui fasse son boulot moi je fais le mien
quand on demande de cuisine entrecôte ou
un filet de boeuf hachée mon job mais
qu'il fasse aussi est-ce que vous pensez
que des clients vous munir de votre
restaurant quand vous allez ouvrir des
gpéens réservations c'est complet c'est
vrai ouais vraiment grave et et donc
vous allez
mine de rien il va avoir les forces de
l'ordre vont venir et à venir et alors
fermé pour faire mais j'ai déjà tout
perdu ou pire des cas mais est-ce que
vous rendez compte que là vous allez
hors-la-loi est est ce que ça vous
dérange
est ce que vous trouvez pas qu'à un
moment donné la république française
n'aurait pas privatiser mon restaurant
en donnant 10 mille balles par mois elle
a privatisé mon restaurant je ne suis
plus propriétaire chez moi je n'ai pas
le droit d'ouvrir les assurances ne paye
pas d'accord on nous donne peu je ne
demande pas le mot et moi je veux juste
bosser c'est ça mon truc moi je veux
travailler je veux que tous mes
collègues de france et de navarre
travail je vais te les employés il est
passé de 100 balles à la fin du mois
mais qu'ils aient leurs salaires je veux
pas que ça tire je veux pas qu'on aille
aux restos du coeur puis à passer de
pauvres enfants
vous comprenez que pour les forces de
l'ordre qui vont venir dans votre
restaurant pour partir de résistance
avec les ça va être compliqué parce que
il compresse unis comprennent mine de
rien votre détresse ils comprennent que
vous êtes dans une dans une tristesse
absolue dans une détresse absolue mais
on leur demande de faire leur travail a
aussi fait prendre un exemple que je
vous ai écoutés de soleure monsieur
bernard montiel qui étaient là tout à
l'heure quand vous avez toujours l'art
du moment sur le vois pas où vous étiez
à 150000 euros de salaire comme des
cyril j'ai tout perdu c'est est ce que
ça fait tout perdre quand on a tous moi
je me suis créé j'ai rien demandé à
personne je me suis fait tout seul
j'ai une famille de 8 on est plein dans
ce cas là on a laissé happer de cuisine
on est pas des génies on est d'accord
pour condamner des travailleurs il était
heureux avant bien sûr que j'étais
heureux je ne demande rien à personne
je demande juste aux pires des cas qui
nous donne une date ou un protocole
pourquoi protocole sanitaire c'est pas
bon pour nous il fonctionne pas dans la
restauration parce qu'une étude
américaine a dit que pour les fast food
c'était pas mon et on pourquoi on sait
pas faire des études en france c'est par
faire des vaccins en france on vous
demandez un psy chaleur de faire des
vaccins vous avez vous êtes vous êtes
mariés non je suis pas marié cette
célibataire
voyez le métier c'est vrai que quand
vous avez travaillé beaucoup vu quand je
vous dis 15 heures par jour c'est pas
une blague le matin bonne session et
bien sûr du ccma vie mais chacun son
contrat vous êtes en train de vous dire
que vous allez perdre votre vide peut
être dans un mois mais on va tout perdre
mais pas moi on est deux cent quarante
mille restaurateurs vous les aimez vos
restaurants en éclats sur les dacquois
vous êtes tous des potes restauration à
vous connaissez les grands chefs et
compagnie donc à un moment donné ou
savez la peine qu'ils ont on n'est pas
en train de pleurer la misère on veut
juste bosser alors mettez les protocoles
en place quel protocole parce que c'est
bien marrant de travailler sur la la la
la logistique et compagnie un pas de
souci à faire du bla bla bla tout le
monde sait faire mais moi je sais le
faire
donc aujourd'hui que le ministre de la
santé prenne ses responsabilités et nous
donne un protocole pour la vaccination
parce qu'on en aura besoin quoi qu'il
arrive vous allez vous faire vacciner
on me demande bien sûr je me faire
vacciner c'est pas le problème mois pour
rassurer les gens je vais la prendre la
photo de la faire moi je vais mettre le
vaccin n'y a pas de problème si ça
m'intéresse pas de faire peur aux gens
en disant je suis pas vacciné non
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous dites
cette décision d'ouvrir le restaurant
n'ouvrir son restaurant que stefano son
restaurant est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec lui parce qu'il nous dit j'ai déjà
tout perdu
qu'est ce qui va m'arriver de pire ou
est quels sont les mots pourriez trouver
question que j'aimerais de lui poser je
comprends vos détresse je suis chef
d'entreprise je vais faire des plans
sociaux on est tous dans la merde ok ce
que j'aimerais savoir c'est quelle est
votre solution par rapport à la
problématique
la problématique c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas recevoir dans les hôpitaux
plus de 5000 ou 7000 personnes mais en
rien est-ce que je suis responsable
non mais moi les gens sont méchants bien
jardiner respire sa maman d on a eu des
mois et des mois
non mais si on veut pas formé de la
révolution il sait pas ce qu un principe
qui on doit le dr stéphane thebaut c'est
lui le pauvre il est il est tributaire
s'excuser mais ça va il est un peu voilà
c'est pas de sa faute d'essayer une
jonction des millions dans ce cas le
porte parole de jaurès mais il faut
arrêter un moment de penser que atteint
lsm explique deux secondes et j'ai fait
1800 ben poser la route voire un sur dix
minutes de mr fillon serait fan ce truc
qui m'inquiète aujourd'hui c'est que ça
fait des mois et des mois quand il
connaît un commis depuis décembre
l'année dernière
gentil restaurateurs que nous sommes et
toutes les entreprises de france on a
joué et joue au premier confinement ça
qu'on s'est t on si tu pars dont on a
fait ce qu'il fallait en a mis les
masques les gestes barrières on est
passé on est resté à la maison
elle affaiblit le payer le prêt bpi qui
va l'assurer une fortune à la france on
va avoir un taux d'endettement je vous
raconte même pas à plus de sous pour les
bouffons restaurant ma crise elle est là
on est vraiment elle est là dans le sens
où et pourquoi ils prennent pas les
bonnes décisions qu'est ce qu'ils
attendent
vous faites quoi vous avez été élu pour
quoi réveillez vous je dire à un moment
donné vous êtes là vous faites nabeul a
blâmé on s'en tape prenez les décisions
qu'il faut si vous continuez demain deux
mois qu'on confirme deux mois et on les
prenne les décisions que si on veut dire
si on vous dit demain on confine deux
mois mais dans deux mois vous allez
ouvrir à l'hérédité way est ce qui vous
énerve et ce qui vous énerve c est dans
le flou faire de travail du personnel
saisonnier j'ai quinze salariés d'accord
mon personnel il vient d'avignon il ya
deux mais s'il vient de marseille de
bordeaux d'accord parce que en franche
comté qui va se répandre réfugier en
hauteur illustration ça veut dire qu'il
faut que je loue des appartements
d'accord je ne sais pas quand est-ce que
je dois aller louer c'est à dire que si
je dois les louer comme moi je doit
rouvrir l'habitude c'est à dire le 12
janvier balaieront qu'on n'ouvrira pas
le genre n'est donc le mettons mois de
février faut que je trouve les
appartements si je dois commencer à
louer des appartements aujourd'hui au
mois de février est bien et que je ferme
que l'on n'est pas ouvert en février en
mars en
oui j'aurais payé 3 mois dix logements
15 euros bien sûr 15 mai roger sur
comment comme ça alors je vais prendre
on est dans le flou qui vous qui vous
assure que je veux dire c'est pas
possible on peut pas rajouter de la
peine à la peine
ça sert à rien ok je vais avoir mené une
bonne fois pas de problème et moins
grands coups de bâton et dites moi
qu'est ce qu'on nous d'accord alors est
ce que vous comprenez moi ça tape à la
révolution cet appel à l'ouverture
voudrait qu'ils restaurent rouge c'était
pas des questions michel moi c'est vrai
que c'est une situation qui est
tellement intenable qu'à un moment on
est tellement au bord du précipice que
je dis quitte à sauter autant sauter ans
avec bravache essaie de s'en sortir mais
j'aurais ses racines depuis que vous
avez lancé ce ce cet appel être hors la
loi par détresse vous avez d'autres
restaurateurs qui sont prêts à vous
suivez qui vont faire pareil que vous le
1er février des centaines d'affaires
comme vous comprenez vous comprenez que
c'est ok vous savez ce qu'on peut faire
de mal en pire des cas honnêtement je
fais juste un les images va demander une
corde on prend une poutre on se met tous
devant on se filme en suspens voilà ce
qui va arriver ça vous pouvez pas faire
ça oui mais moi j'ai déjà connu une
faillite
moi je sais ce que c'est que la faillite
un dj déjà plante un resto je sais d'où
je viens chez qui je suis ouvrier et je
me suis fait tout seul et on s'est tous
fait dans ce métier tout seul on dit que
c'est un métier de passion mais plus
pardon je vais pas dire de gros mots
mais dans l'absolu je dire à un moment
donné il faut prendre ses
responsabilités ça ne compte pas je suis
restaurateur chef d'entreprise je suis
respectueux de ma clientèle respectueux
mais salariés respectueux de la
hiérarchie de la république
1 je tiens à le dire je suis pas un
révolutionnaire je m'appelle pas aux
vestiaires oui je vais pas sortir la
guillotière genre les maquereaux me tâte
est terminée non c'est pas ça que je lui
dit moi on fait quoi
c'est vous chef du bateau si vous qui
avez les commandes ni d'idées quoi alors
et stéphane joue son jeu sont émus quand
vous parler parce qu'elle joue son jeu
sans vraiment et une détresse joues sont
au bout du rouleau vous avez envie de
savoir vous avez tant le besoin de
réponses en fait si demain je vous dis
que vous avez un cancer nous offrir vous
aimeriez savoir pour combien de temps il
me coupe 1 combien temps vous reste la
ville remercie pour l'exemple
parce que sa part si demain si demain si
demain j'avais un cancer j'aimerais bien
savoir quand est-ce que je vais mourir à
peu près pour pouvoir mes proches ma
famille et compagnie dans mais là pour
vous vous êtes vous êtes dans ce cas le
gouvernement et le cancer de mon métier
parce qu'il ne prend pas de décision ne
fait pas de quartier
fais pas d'histoires
une distanciation sociale oui pour ces
listes on pouvait penser que vous pouvez
encore vous sauver qui ou le restaurant
comme penser que oui je peux encore le
sauver ça veut dire qu'il faut que
j'emprunte encore de l'argent vous
comprenez qu'à quarante deux ans quand
on a mis un demi million sur la table
c'est beau c'est énorme si vous
comprenez notre maison mais moi j'ai
investi toute ma vie je travaille comme
un forçat mes équipes me suivre tous les
gens qui sont passionnés de la
restauration sont fédérateurs et les
équipes les suivre mes apprentis ils
travaillent comme des fous mais on peut
y travaillent comme des fous mais parce
qu'ils savent on a une passion commune
et on la défend tous les restaurateurs
qui font ce métier
les hôteliers des cafetiers les tout ce
que voulaient les perches man tout on
peut en mettre dans tous les sens mais
surtout le corps de métier l'hôtellerie
restauration et du tourisme en général
on se bat pour ça on aime faire plaisir
aux gens on va pas les mettre en danger
c'est pas ça que j'ai dit chic un moment
donné l'immobilisme de ce gouvernement
la non prise des décisions me font aller
au charbon et ils vont me faire couler
parce qu'ils ne prennent pas des
décisions si demain j'ai une gangrène
audois si vous coupez le web on coupe le
doigt sur alors dit moi mon couple donc
c'est quoi on attend la grangrène
jusqu'au bras c'est sûr qu est ce qu est
ce que vous êtes d'accord j'aimerais
will donner votre avis il est pas là
pour poser des questions à stéphane un
jeu quand vous voyez sur cette série cet
appel à la révolution qui n'ont
stéphanois je comprends évidemment votre
colère et votre exaspération et c'est
absolument bouleversant j'ai plein
d'amis cuisiner plein d'amis chef est
une galère et sont tristes ils sont des
passionnés peuvent exercer leur métier
c'est absolument affreux et pour autant
qu'est ce qu'ils font les autres pays
comment ça se passe et revolver en
angleterre nom en angleterre au portugal
s'est ouvert aux états unis s'est ouvert
sous verre partout
ces dix mots là qu on est tous d'accord
bien sûr vous allez souvent manteau
monaco pas de problème vous allez là-bas
allez donnez moi le nombre de copies de
déclarer par les restaurants oui c'est
non mais c'est vrai que les restes d'une
montée du coc vite juste aux larmes
parce qu'à noël il ya plein de gens qui
font de la france qui sont partis à
monaco il parle d'une remontée du
coville qui serait au plus fort dans le
côté haut du côté sud de la france ce
trouble est ma mère et je reviendrai
gens sont charmants des gens qui se
disent bien sûr si tu vas je prends
l'exemple aujourd'hui j'ai une amie qui
m'envoie une petite vidéo d'un hôpital
où elle fait vous savez les petites
pochettes bleus ouais mais ils étaient
au moins 3000 pas de distanciation
social les gens ils veulent aller voir
toutes les zones commerciales
j'allais faire mes courses comme tout le
monde est bien sûr mais ces ondes c'est
blindé s'est blindée et maccoyii
regarder ce que je veux dire un moment
j'ai pris le train tout à l'heure c'est
archi bondé mais c'est quoi ces nombreux
demain c'est l'inconnu est ce que vous
allez suivre un protocole sanitaire
strychnine la question jeudi pour la
questionner sur les milieux bien sûr on
arrive mais moi je comprends tellement
votre désarroi votre détresse vous si
c'est honteux que ça se passe comme ça
pour les restaurateurs
ils sont en train de crever c'est là
qu'on a ce monsieur qui en train de nous
dire je vais [ __ ] la clé sous la porte
sur 20 ans que je fais ça j'ai appris
nous on est là mais rien la maman vous
l'avez fait pour l'eau pendant le
déconfinement on a vu que ça
fonctionnait très bien dans le
restaurant les plexi que c'est à tous
les restaurateurs se sont écoulés
monsieur stéphane tétouan 2 2 goals en
face à boeing
non mais ça peut faire ça peut pas se
passer comme ça on peut pas regarder les
gens crever ça fait quand même très bien
réjouissant et ses ouailles à peine les
sensations ils ont fait ça très bien
fonctionné pour qu'on laisse pas rouvrir
dans il est ouvert aux non classés ont
noué les impatiences non non non vous la
grande récré le demanderait mais c'est
honteux
léon là tu prends tu prends l'avion
né comme ça et on voit dans la mascotte
alright boom aussi dans le reste aussi
c'est un stack la domann d'achat désolé
pour tous les mouvements populaires
aucune évidence et ça commence comme les
phases de rajouter quelque chose tu es
fan je suis désolé pour toutes les
personnes qui ont perdu un être cher
j'ai perdu un ami la semaine dernière on
a entendu c'est un de mes clients un
petit papy 80 80 est mort du co vide
d'accord c'est un mec super et était
géniale voilà j'en connais quelques-uns
qui sont mort du co vide ok pas de souci
je regrette ça j'en dirais je comprends
je regrette je comprends les difficultés
des familles je regrette d'accord sauf
qu'aujourd'hui
moi quand on m'a demandé de faire un
protocole sanitaire on l'a mis en place
ok on a bien vous avez mal argent oui
oui c'est pas que ça nous a coûté des
millions voilà un mais soyons honnête
oui mais à part que tu éliminé parce que
moi j'ai pas mis du plexiglas pas quand
tu dors la grande nature pas pourquoi
mais parce qu'aujourd'hui les assurances
ne veulent pas payer serait la faille
des assurances de bien sûr on est
d'accord
à la veille des nations aujourd'hui eh
ben vous annonce quand même ce ne sera
pas la faillite des assurances ne sera
pas la faille des restaurateurs ce sera
la faillite d'un état entier d'accord
parce que je vous signale que si la
personne pour cotiser à la sécurité
sociale
demain y'a plus de sécurité sociale
parce que c'est nous qui sommes les
cotisations de charges c'est nous qui
donnons la tva c'est nous qui payons le
spread a ce prix la sacem et en veux tu
en voilà
donc n'oubliez pas que un million de
d'employés qui cotisent pour la france
c'est pour cotiser pour le global de
tout le monde c'est 10 % du pib français
enlevés 10% du pib pensée et vous verrez
ce qui restera de la sécurité sociale à
travers quoi privatiser la sécurité
sociale ça qu'ils vont faire pas
possible donc aujourd'hui moi je dis on
our j'appelle tous mes collègues tous
mes collègues restaurateurs vous avez
raison mais à un moment donné je
comprends que ce soit dangereux je veux
mettre personne en danger
je dis juste que ouvrez ouvrez parce que
c'est le symbolique qui compte mais
complet juste sur les prêts à l'aidant à
risque
vous seriez prêt parce que je pense
sincèrement que dans les restaurants qui
sont gérés normalement il ya peu vous
seriez dans leurs tirs sur avait bien
sûr le problème c'est sa illégal
le problème c'est pas les restaurants 7
et toute cette terrasse c'était dans un
but unique à boire des coups alors
l'avenir c'est pas les respecter c'est
donc il fallait faire attention entre
ceux qui avaient effectivement
restaurants gérés correctement avec des
avec un espace moi j'étais manger au
restaurant à l'époque tous les jours y
avait effectivement un mètre ou mettez
deux mascottes ont soulevé par aux
toilettes c'est pas là il voit un
problème le vrai problème c'est quoi
c'est tout c'est bas qui m'ont versé ces
boîtes de nuit qui ont été improvisés
parce qu'il a plu boîte de nuit mais
qu'avaient débat avec des des boissons
ça c'est un vrai progrès de 2 secondes
et le procès que l'état dans ces moments
là ils font ils bon allez disons ferme
tout alors qu'il était évident tout le
monde c'est parce que tout le monde l'a
vu que le premier n'est pas né ne sont
pas les restaurants nos téléspectateurs
est ce que vous allez dans un restaurant
bar restaurant le troisième set où ces
endroits appropriés pour faire la fête
c'est ça qui est diffusée par jeu juste
j'ose dire par là que j'ai payé une tête
d'une hôtesse d'accueil chez moi dans
mon restaurant qui a mis du gel dans les
mains de tous les clients bien sûr
pendant quatre mois
on s'est cassé la tête mettez le masque
mettez du gel pas plus de 4 à l'ail pas
plus de à la cave
attention les toilettes mais j'ai quand
même une terrasse je dis pas ça pour
rien mais on a quand même une terrasse
de 300 m² chez nous en extérieur
d'accord un gros restaurant avoir un
hectare de terrain donc je veux dire il
ya de l'espace je comprends que dans les
petits restaurants ce soit compliqué un
coup c'est eux qu'il faut aider d'accord
mais les gros comme moi par les gros les
restaurants de taille normale si humaine
qui pourront s'en sortir
laissez nous travailler et aider les
petits caïds et les discothèques aider
le monde
votre monde celui du spectacle vous en
avez combien nations du monde du
spectacle théâtre off très gros et bcd
restaurateurs comme nous ils fondent
mais merci c'est un monde cetim et une
tourisme de la passion la musique
vous en connaissez combien qui sont à la
rue qui ont rien là bas c'est isabelle
pouvait dire un tout petit truc
les restaurateurs vous dites on a
toujours tout fait pour les clients ils
sont en sécurité oui c'est eux qui vous
met en danger parce que moi j'ai insisté
à paris dans le nombre de restaurants
des restaurateurs au bord de la crise de
nerfs et qui était en larmes en disant
ils ne comprennent pas qu'on est là pour
eux et les clients se mettaient et
s'agglutinaient refusés met le gel
refusé de mettre le masque autour des
très grands ça ne pose pas de souci je
vais rebondir le puits
ça n'existait pas de paris c'est pas la
france non bien sûr accor paris c'est la
capitale
on gère pas paris mais d'accord depuis
paris en dix ans paris c'est la capitale
et c'est la france c'est faux d'accord
le reste de la france nous on est des
gens du cru on se dira aux gens et quand
on vous dit m le ask mais tel geste
lavez vous les mains bon après il ya la
table après il ya des parisiens qui sont
extraits bien sûr les lacs et on a les
mêmes chez nous c'était un problème à un
moment donné et il ya des gens qui
savent respecter les choses d'accord tu
veux pas respecté tu me rappelles toi
mais rien à faire à manger pas de
problème et vient pas chez nos fans
aujourd'hui bah oui mais c'est que soit
votre situation j'aimerais qu'on vient
sur votre situation
quel est votre appel et combien de temps
pouvait tenir encore alors ma plus
grosse problématique c'est que j'ai
encore beaucoup emprunté match en train
demande était d'accord j'ai fait un
plongeon qui a lieu chaque mois qui
passe chaque jour qui passe sa tendresse
encore plus en dette puisque toute la
trésorerie ge avait amassé parce qu'on a
très bien travaillé cette épaule ou la
bulgarie siméon nashar bonnet pour
s'assurer mais si vous le méritez bien
sûr on à charbonnier pour on s'est dit
allez on fait on fait partie des efforts
de guerre on a fermé deux mois tant pis
aller on prendra plus de couverts on va
tabasser voilà on a récupéré ce qu'on
l'avait quasiment perdu voit pas tout à
fait mais ce qu'on avait quasiment perdu
pour arriver à un delta qui était qui
était convenable sauf que ben on a déjà
les traites et les prêts en cours on a
perdu un peu d'argent quand même sur sur
les mois de fermeture et derrière on
nous demande de réemprunter et il est un
lui ai dit on vous a aidé tu m'as aidé
de quoi j ai je me suis endetté mais je
m'endette et puis là tu me donnes limite
tous les mois mais qui c'est qui va
payer tuant d'être le pays
c'est ça la solution endettés en
déterrant d'été en été sans déconner
mais ça veut dire qu'il faut donner
donner le chômage à tout le monde
pendant que jamais fait ça pourquoi pas
et puis on paye plus ce n'est pas donné
mais la tva 5,5 ça va m'aider
tu as fait non mais ils font un report
des traites cd génie c'est à dire qu'en
fait c'est comme si on allait régler
non mais c'est comme si on allait régler
le problème de trésorerie avec un report
de trets et ses fabuleux c'est juste en
fait tu reporte le problème c'est
reculer pour mieux sauter et vous allez
voir ce qui va se passer à court terme
ou à moyen terme là les gens vont se
soulever minutes du spectacle aussi
c'est pareil la restauration faut
arrêter d'être des moutons des espèces
de 65
un seul sera 65% pays pourquoi parce que
les gens ont eu là certaines personnes
non excusez-moi ya certaines personnes
qui étaient déjà en difficulté info
savoir le psg ou lille à remonter un
petit coup bien sûr et les sauver la
première femme à qui il aurait eu avant
le confinement donc cela ils vont nous
faire défaut d'accord défaut de paiement
les banques vont trinquer nous
contribuables que nous sommes
nous allons trinquer maintenant on va
perdre des emplois d'accord on va perdre
de la crédibilité nous restaurateurs
puisqu'on sera lé mal vu les pestiférés
du coin et en plus on rajoute à la dette
de la dette de la d200 harris et combien
la dette on prendrait gens s'étaient pas
on a vu votre coup de gueule sur
facebook est ce que vous voulez redire
ce que vous avez dit ce matin quel est
votre appel quelle est votre cri de
détresse j'ai envie de dire on les 240
millions les deux cent quarante mille
restaurateurs aujourd'hui d'accord plus
tout le monde du spectacle pour naples
et plein d'autres d'accord n'a sûrement
pas aller dans la rue pour casser paris
ça sert à rien pensez à ces gens qui eux
ont conduit ça et puis ça sert un verre
ça qu'ils sont dans une galère aussi je
suis pas pour un chu et bien moi je suis
pas là je suis pas un gilet jaune je
suis personne embellie gilet jaune bien
qu'on n'a rien à manger je m'explique je
vais pas les casseurs dans la rue et je
vous le dis c'est stéphane léger les
jaunes c'est pas des casseurs
non mais 595% dit les jo ne s'est pas
desserrée c'est pas ça non j'ai pas les
mêmes revendications que sa soeur jana m
j'ai pas les mêmes ronger l'occasion des
gens demandent le droit de travailler
oui mais les gilet jaune aussi demandent
le droit de crier et à se rendre chez
moi dans la maison que j'ai construit ok
donc ce que je demande aujourd'hui aux
restaurateurs
c'est bien il faut faire un coup d'éclat
qu'est ce qu'il va faire il valait
fermer 240 milles restaurateurs ouvrez
les remontées mécaniques
ouvrez tous les tire fesses ouvrez tous
parce qu'à un moment donné ok je vais
avoir le club vous appelé tout le monde
à ouvrir la rescousse et de la
symbolique au pire des cas je demande
pas que les gens se mettent en danger
c'est parce que je dis mais que la
clientèle ils peuvent penser soit
solidaire de ses restaurants et au fait
vous savez que la nuit de 2021 c'est
quand même l'année de la gastronomie en
france mais ça commence quand mais ça
commence dans la rue ça commence mais ça
commencera jamais ma foi donc c'est une
hérésie
on aimait son et connaissent pays c'est
n'importe quoi alors aux puits au pire
des cas comme il s'appelait votre
collègue qui parlait très bien tout à
l'heure j'ai mis mon
je vais nommer comme ministre de la
santé apparemment il sait ce qu'il faut
faire et je pense qu'il parle bien il
sait de quoi il parle
donc nos mon cher monsieur là et que le
président de la république nomme les
bonnes personnes à la tête de l'état et
qu'ils se fassent conseiller mieux que
ça d'accord parce que 35 gars qui
viennent connaissais rien à rien on va
pas avancer
ok c'est comme si moi je m'étais 35
massant dans ma cuisine je pas sûr
qu'ils savaient le faire une truite aux
bleus 1 donc après on va voir ce que
pensent ces téléphones oui à 60 bien sûr
merci stéphane en tout cas d'avoir écrit
avec nous